we have some interesting news on the
fight to remove George Anthony devolder
Santos from the House of Representatives
house Democrats have filed a resolution
led by Democratic Congressman Robert
Garcia
to expel yes to expel George Santos from
the House of Representatives
um it is the latest escalation writes
axios of Democrats efforts to public
punish Santos for the serial
Fabrications about his background I I
have not been super familiar with
Congressman Robert Garcia up until now
he has an unbelievable sense of timing
listen to this interview in which he
says you know Santos is a lot like me uh
Latino gay except he lies about
everything this is so funny as an openly
gay person as an immigrant as a Latino I
look at uh Mr Santos as someone who's
actually very similar to me except that
he lies about everything and So within
within our own lgbtq Community there's
like major disgust in what he's doing
and his representation of our community
and so it's not acceptable for him to
lie about every single part of his past
including uh uh now getting classified
information uh or access to it so it's
just it's time that honest the final
straw was getting access to giving
action being a given access class of
information you literally getting some
of this a thriving liar
um access to America's Secrets yeah so
of course I agree completely with Robert
Garcia I would not you know if a few of
you emailed me after this story broke
and said David this is such a waste of
time Republic applicants control the
House of Representative there is just no
way in hell that this goes anywhere you
know the you're probably right but it is
true that there are some Republicans who
are disgusted by uh George Santos and
they've said it if Mitt Romney were in
the House of Representatives rather than
the Senate I am a hundred percent sure
that Romney would join Democrats in a
vote to remove George Santos so because
the majority for Republicans is quite
small it is not completely out of the
question that you find that Democrats
find just enough Republicans to maybe
get rid of George Santos do I think it's
the most likely outcome no but is this
worth doing and try to get a vote and
try to get Republicans on the record get
them to say no I vote for Santos to stay
I actually do think it's a good idea in
this particular case now I am not
someone who as a blanket
says symbolic votes in the house are
either worth it or not worth it wastes
of time or good uses of time I don't
have a generic
umbrella view on that I am balancing in
my assessment
is it really guaranteed to be symbolic
only or is there actually a chance that
you might pass it what would we achieve
by putting members on the record by
getting them to vote one way or another
you know when we think back to that
Force the vote Medicare for all thing we
really knew the positions of basically
every every member of Congress on that
issue I actually don't know the
positions of every member of the House
on whether they would vote to keep or
expel George Santos and it actually is a
close enough margin now that it that at
least theoretically it could work I
think this is an interesting idea good
for Robert Garcia good for Democrats
let's see if we ultimately get a vote on
it here's the perfect last minute
Valentine's Day gift one of our sponsors
paired is the app that offers you daily
questions games and guided conversations
for couples designed by clinical
psychologists an independent study by
open University found couples who use
paired for three months see an average
36 percent increase in the quality of
their relationship every day paird sends
you and your partner prompts designed to
let you emotionally connect in a
meaningful way you don't see their
answer until you've answered and using
paired just a few minutes a day lets you
build a deeper knowledge of yourself and
your partner boost intimacy there are
hilarious moments as well my girlfriend
and I have been using it and it is
really funny and interesting so this
Valentine's Day give a gift that will
last beyond the holiday go to paired.com
Pacman get a seven day free trial and 25
off a subscription even the free trial
makes an awesome gift see if you like it
the link is down below